[Music]
the strategic homeland division referred
to as the division is a classified unit
of highly trained self supportive
tactical agents who love unobtrusively
among us the main objective of the
division is to ensure the continuity of
government in case for catastrophic
emergency released in waves division
agents are activated when all other
forms of public protection have failed
they are the last line of defense but
what brought about the creation of the
division in the first place
[Music]
the division story is actually been
largely based around real world
organizations and events the first of
these could be dated back to 2001
operation dark winter operation dark
winter was the code name for a
bioterrorist attack simulation conducted
in June 2001 it was designed to carry
out a mock version of a covert and
widespread smallpox attack on the United
States sound familiar
Dark Wind was focused on evaluating the
inadequacies of a national emergency
response during the use of the
biological weapon against the American
population the exercise was solely
intended to establish preventative
measures and response strategies by
increasing governmental and public
awareness of the magnitude and potential
of such a threat the simulated scenario
involves an initial smallpox attack on
Oklahoma City with additional smallpox
attacks on Georgia and Pennsylvania the
simulation was then designed to spiral
out of control this would create a
situation in which the National Security
Council would struggle to determine both
the origin of the attack as well as deal
with the containment of the virus by not
be able to keep pace with the rate at
which the disease was able to spread a
new issue emerges in which massive
civilian casualties would overwhelm
America's emergency response
capabilities the disastrous
contingencies that would result in a
massive loss of civilian life
we used to exploit the weaknesses of the
US healthcare infrastructure and its
inability to handle such a threat the
contingencies were also meant to address
the widespread panic that would emerge
which would result in mass social
breakdown and mob violence dark winter
outlined several key findings on top of
the possibility of massive civilian
casualties breakdowns and essential
institutions resulted in the loss of
confidence in government in turn leading
to civil disorder and a violation of the
democratic processes by authorities
attempting to restore order shortages of
vaccines and other drugs affected the
response available to contain the
epidemic as well as the ability of
political leaders to offer reassurance
to the public
this lead to great public anxiety and it
has a significant effect on the
decisions taken by the political
leadership
due to the institutionally limited surge
capacity of the American healthcare
system hospitals quickly would have been
overwhelmed and rendered effectively
inoperable
by the sudden and continued influx of
new cases this was only made worse by
patients with common illnesses who
feared they might have smallpox and
people who are otherwise healthy but
concerned about the possible exposure
the challenges of making a correct
diagnosis and rationing the limited
resources combined with the shortages of
health care staff who were themselves
worried about becoming infected impose a
huge burden on the health care system
also the ability to reassure and educate
the general public in this potential
crisis failed on a surprising level
strategy is deferred on the best path to
maintain order of such an attack
occurred if operation dark winter had
been an actual attack the US government
was woefully unprepared
the outcome of operation dark winter led
the Bush administration to pass the
national security and Homeland Security
presidential directive otherwise known
as directive 51 directive 51 s purpose
is to maintain continuity of government
in the event of catastrophic emergency
defined as any incident regardless of
the location that results in
extraordinary levels of mass casualties
damage or disruption severely affecting
the u.s. population infrastructure
environment economy or government
functions the directive contains annex
is so classified even members of
Congress on the Homeland Security
Committee are denied access to them it
grants the president draconian powers
including the suspension of all
elections the complete subordination of
federal and local government departments
to the executive branch and the
extension of military command into
civilian life in game it's speculated
that part of the continuity of
government plans could include the
creation of secret autonomous military
cells with no rules of engagement
dispersed throughout society going about
the normal lives waiting to be activated
by the outbreak of an emergency like a
pandemic again the speculation comes
from real-world events like NATO
stay-behind covert cells that were
established across Europe by m16 during
the Second World War to prepare for the
possibility of an imminent Soviet attack
established as sleeper cells that were
quickly spring into action of the USSR
decided to force its way into Europe
during the Cold War there also so secret
that even national governments knew
nothing about their existence National
Security presidential directive 51 or
directive 51 for short was quietly
posted on the White House website on May
9th 2007 this was not the first secret
of directive that a president of the
United States has signed but it was the
first to have had a small portion of it
made available to the public
portions that were made public referred
to a separation of powers two of each of
the branches of government making each
of the branches possible of maintaining
government without coordinating with the
other branches to uphold the framework
of the Constitution
could a story like the division actually
occur in real life it's actually less
unbelievable than you may think but we
need to remember that this is a story
based on simulations it's certainly not
a prediction however there are a few
things that be taken away from this not
necessarily from of bioterrorism point
of view but through the way that we as a
society function and how we would react
if the large-scale disaster was to
strike but this is probably a topic
better suited to a different video after
hearing this and all of the historical
and real-world events that have brought
the division story to life you can't
help but think is it possible that there
are real-world division types sleeper
agents around us and with this in mind
the big question is who do I have to
serenade to get some of that bad air
shade Tech
thanks again to my patreon for being
able to help me continue to produce
these types of videos particularly mr.
Devereau if you're wanting to become one
of the fabulous few check out my patreon
page also we have an amazing group of
people in the disco community helping
each other out lately including a few
streamers I try to jump into them from
time to time but if you're wanting any
help with commendations
or finishing some of those shields check
it out they're a crazy bunch but super
friendly it's definitely become a go-to
place to chat about games lately I'll
ever link to both of these in the
description thanks for checking out the
video and if you have any suggestions
for what you'd like to see from me in
the future let me know in the comments
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you